m
nous sommes tous au bout de ses fils
tous connectés et ça ils le savent a
raison pour laquelle 43 étudiants de
l'iut de saint-pierre en réseaux et
télécommunications rencontre le milieu
professionnel avec la visite de la
direction de lee organisation et de la
modernisation des services de la
collectivité départementale
vous savez à peu près combien il peut y
avoir d'agent donc on conseil
départemental en est on est cinq mille
cinq cents ça leur permet de découvrir
donc les métiers et puis de pouvoir voir
un petit peu ce qu'on fait réellement
par rapport à leur formation théorique
ce qui se passe en pratique dans une
collectivité d'une taille aussi
importante que la nôtre avec tous les
métiers que ça représente
à plus d'une centaine d'applications
métier qu'il faut qu'il faut gérer
on est en quelque sorte une petite
société de services au sein d'une grande
collectivité quel département
et cette qualité cette société de
services elle a vraiment pour objectif à
la fois de fournir des services et des
équipements aux agents du département
est de faire en sorte que les usagers
puissent accéder aux services publics du
département de façon dématérialisée
3523 ordinateurs fixes et portables 413
imprimantes 140 sites interconnecté 150
serveurs avec des applications ou encore
1500 interventions traités par mois
les 53 agents de cette direction ne
chôme pas
dans le concret des apprentissages
qu'ils font dans le cadre des
enseignements du ctic soyaux souvent
théoriques ou pratiques
et de voir que le matériel sur lequel
ils travaillent les logiciels c'était du
travail sont réellement utilisés dans
les entreprises dans les administrations
du coup en même temps ça leur montre ce
qui se fait le jour j les le j'ai
entendu le discours d' déjà du directeur
du service qui leur a dit
qu'effectivement il faut innover on est
en plein
c'est le message qu'on veut leur faire
passer c'est qu'il faut innover qu'il
faut toujours bougé faut toujours
remettre en cause ses connaissances et
on les remet en cause comment en voyant
comment ces bruits le monde du travail
aujourd'hui le deuxième groupe
c'est ça donc moi mon job c'est de
m'occuper de ces machines
son cd armoire informatique nous sommes
dans une salle blanche comme vous pouvez
le voir ce qu'on appelle salle blanche
une salle serveurs etc la salle la plus
importante au niveau informatique du
conseil départemental
on est arrivé aussi à ce stade là c'est
qu'on ne vire 13 virtualisé les serveurs
nick mans ont bien failli aussi le
stockage
pas toujours facile de comprendre leur
langage mais cette jeune génération a
l'air ravi du passage de connaissances
que vous voyez pas tardé dans des temps
des services informatiques et dans cette
collectivité mais là c'est bien bien
plus grand que ce que j'imaginais et ya
beaucoup beaucoup plus de gens paient
qu'est ce que je pensais aussi mais on a
découvert comment il fonctionnait
qu'est-ce qui gérait tout et c'est bien
fait et c'est intéressant
allez pour l'instant est pas été
surprise exactement ouaip et les métiers
une habitude et autant à l'école de voir
une parle de métier xterra mais la voix
on voit vraiment ce que ce qui se passe
sur le terrain ce qu'ils font et c'est
assez intéressant c'est vrai quand on
parle de choses à apprendre
infrastructures du nu chic c'est assez
complexe
surtout grâce à des serveurs c'est un
immense et si on voit le bureau des
temps devant les siens on pense un peu
un bureau travail n'en faudrait mener un
travail de bureau
c'est un bon travail de assez intense
est important tu imaginé que c'était
comme ça au département à part le crétin
on sait pas ce qui préoccupe plus calme
puis tout s'est vraiment intéressés je
pense qu'ils ont des journées bien
remplies et bien l'intention chacun
d'entre nous a une fois dans sa vie
était accompagné par les services du
conseil départemental et si ça marche
c'est un peu grâce à ces hommes de
l'ombre